welcome to another episode of ask IJ I
heard I just seen the spot a henway
what's a henway about
5 will she answer today I just can't
wait
J we're going to start this episode with
a question from Gracie who asks if I am
excited for VidCon and let me tell you
what yes I am excited as of now VidCon
is less than a week away and I cannot
wait to see all of you guys I'm doing a
bunch of panels and doing a bunch of
meetups and signings and all of this
crazy stuff so be sure to check the
official VidCon website for a full
schedule of course follow me on Twitter
because I will be tweeting pretty much
why am I doing this with my hand it's
like this it's like what's going on hand
hand put these Down Casey J wants to
know what my favorite way is to annoy my
sister Brienne like filming her or
chasing her around the house with my
remote control helicopter to be
completely honest with you my favorite
way to annoy her is actually I'm seeing
The Little Mermaid and she is getting so
annoying so watch this look at
this we need to
get me and my other sister Jenna will
also find songs and replace words in the
song with brienne's name hey I heard Bri
was a wild
one see we did that change it up a
little bit a little Bri put Bri's name
in it mm the new way that I've enjoyed
annoying my sister is using my aistin
helicopter and flying it around while
she's trying to take a nap ready let
[Music]
go 5 minutes oh no it's coming towards
me you're good Jen bye oh no actually
want to get an iine helicopter they are
on sale until Monday so if you want to
get one you might as well get one while
50% off because that's the only way to
shop sales sal sal sal sales
sales next question do cool wants to
know how I became the host of Friday
Night Fights some of you guys might not
even know what Friday Night Fights is
it's a shell that's only on Call of Duty
Elite I'm Justine and tonight on Friday
Night Fights we're bringing some Allstar
Talent into our Arena vage Jackson is
most wellknown for his UFC fighting
skills but on his way to the fights he
likes to play some Call of Duty in his
limo but how I became the host I played
in the first season as a competitor and
the next season they were looking for a
new host and they asked me and I said
yes Jack what am I most looking forward
to in Black Ops 2 zombies if I had one
makeup product to use for the rest of my
life what can I not live without and
it's chapstick it's me Laura you want
Study tips from me and my sister Jenna
no you do not me and my sister are the
most add crazy people when it comes to
studying she's supposed to be studying
and I log on to Xbox Live what's Jenna
doing she's playing Call of Duty so my
tip to you is to lock yourself in a room
with no distractions just your study
materials probably end up tearing the
carpet from that said room that I locked
myself in and not studying at all when
I'm away from home does my Lego I
justtin run away no it's it's Legos it's
not real what she does do is sit right
here next to my dining table right next
to the kitchen doing absolutely nothing
just patiently waiting for an earthquake
what should we show bre show Bri teeth
it's another one that wait change the
name do I like One Direction I I think I
do but to be completely honest I've only
heard the one song where he's talking
about the girl she doesn't know that
she's beautiful but everybody else does
and she walks in the room and all of
this nonsense is happening whatever girl
that song is about she knows she's
beautiful because let me tell you what
these radio stations Serious XM
everywhere is always playing just know
she's beautiful she knows she knows
trust me trust me you've told her since
that's the only song that I've really
heard to base my One Direction liking on
I'm going to have to get back you on
that one have you ever done the cinnamon
challenge think that answers your
question Ray I'm going to kidnap
you okay okay calling the cops
now be right
back woo guess what I forgot to do in
the last episode of ask J that was to
feature your YouTube comments and since
I don't have any here that means you
guys need to leave me some basically in
my past episodes I have asked you guys
to say hey put me in an episode of ask
and then I put your comments here well I
forgot to ask you guys in the last
episode so leave a comment below saying
justtin put me in the next episode of
asky J and also if you guys want to make
a video response with a question please
do because I would love to start
answering video response questions
because they're always so much fun and
actually get to see you guys feature you
in the videos thank you guys so much for
watching this episode I will see you all
in the next episode but in the meantime
don't forget to subscribe and check out
the rest of my YouTube channels which I
sometimes update m see you guys at Vicon
[Music]
bye